Alright, you're done.
let's take a look at the solution.
Now we're going to need some TextViews.
First of all let's look
at our LinearLayout.
It's vertical.
We're going to want it to be horizontal.
The next thing we're going to want
are a bunch of TextViews.
let's just drag them in.
Now remember, we had all those ID's
that were given to us in the last quiz.
The first one is the
list_item_date_TextView,
and we'll give it some text
that makes sense
when we help to layout the layout.
We'll remove this before
we actually submit it to our project.
And for fun, let's switch to landscape.
It'll make things a little more legible.
Also, let's just zoom in a little bit.
Alright, so that's our
list_item_date_TextView.
Now, right next to that,
we want another TextView.
Since we want the design to be the same,
this one doesn't need to have an ID.
If you remember, our design had the date,
followed by a dash,
followed by the Forecast,
followed by the high,
followed by a slash,
followed by low.
So this is just going to be a view
that contains a dash.
And we can even hardcode this in for now.
Then we're going to create
another TextView next to that.
Our placeholder text
will be a forecast, like clear.
The ID for this will be
list_item_forecast_TextView.
Now we need another TextView.
Once again, this one's
not going to have an ID
because we don't need it.
And we'll add another dash.
Now we're actually getting
to the high and low forecasts.
Let's say a high of 23,
one more plain TextView,
this one with a slash,
and once again, with no ID.
And for our high forecast,
it better be list_item_high_text_view.
Finally, we'll add
one more plain TextView.
This one will be for our low,
and of course,
that means it's going to be
list_item_low_text_view.
And there we have it,
our multiple TextView Layout.
Now we might want to make this prettier,
but this is a good start,
and it just plays
the four fields that we asked for.
They're all part of a LinearLayout.
Before we actually would submit this,
let's remove the placeholder tags
for everything except for
the static fields.
We'll also have to remove
these empty IDs,
it's actually important to understand
what's going on in these TextViews.
And there we have it, that's what
your layout should look like,
at least if you want to make
it look almost identical
to the layout we started out with.
Of course you can go wild
with these designs
and there's a lot you can do
with the layout editor
and with different kinds of layouts.
We'll be learning more
about that in the next lesson.
Alright, we finally get to start
hooking this up to our UX.
Let's go back to ForecastFragment.